So you've become the Elden Lord.
But before you,
it was Radagon, and before him
it was Godfrey,
who items call the "First Elden Lord."
And yet, even before Godfrey,
there was another, Placidusax.
An ancient dragon who ruled as Elden Lord
in the prehistoric age before the Erdtree.
It's him and his kin that you're going
to be learning about in this video.
But to quickly summarise:
First, there were the ancient dragons
who had these stone scales
that could twist time,
making them essentially immortal.
And yet some ancient dragons can be found
dead. Buried in the rocks of Farum Azula,
which twists and crumbles
in an eternal storm.
On the ground, their descendants roam
the Lands Between without the stone
scales of their ancestors.
And instead of stone scales, they've
inherited aspects of their environments.
The ice dragons roam the icy mountaintops.
The glintstone dragons
feasted on sorcerers.
One's hatred was so strong
that he even endured
The Scarlet Rot in Caelid.
And it's here in Caelid,
that Greyoll, mother
of all the mortal dragons, lies dying.
There's a lot to talk about.
This is the story of Elden Ring's Dragons.
Many item descriptions note
that the age of the ancient
dragons was "prehistoric."
And, I think that's an important word,
because it might explain
why Godfrey's recorded
title is the "First Elden Lord."
Even though he's not.
Placidusax is. The word
"prehistoric" denotes
a period of time before written history.
And while there are spoken
legends from this time,
I think what they're trying to get across
is that the Elden Lord
before Godfrey wouldn't be well known.
This was before the age of the Erdtree,
after all, and the Erdtree
would eventually come to be considered
perfect and eternal.
So the idea that
there might have even been
an Elden Lord that came before
could have been considered
irrelevant at best, and sacrilegious,
I think, at worst.
But what really is an Elden Lord?
And why was Placidusax considered one?
I feel like the role of Elden Lord can be
roughly narrowed down to three things.
You are made eligible by A) your strength.
B) your validity as a consort
and/or C) your willingness
to bring about a new age or order.
Specifically, the Elden Lord is tasked
with bringing about The Greater
Will's order, one built around the Elden
Ring that it sent here long ago.
Hence the name, "Elden Lord."
Sounds simple, but then remember,
the nature of The Greater Will's
order can vary wildly, as is shown
by all who come to
champion it over the ages.
The Greater Will's order
is malleable enough
that it can even accept a number
of endings that our Tarnished brings about,
where the Elden Ring is mended by runes
that will dramatically redefine the world.
So it is that our role as a Tarnished
is actually pretty unique,
as our primary goal
now is to reunite the broken shards
of the Elden Ring with Markia, the god
that is the vessel of the Elden Ring
Locked away inside the Erdtree.
It's not up to her to will
a new age into being.
It's up to us,
and we have to gather
the great runes to do this.
So it is, that in most endings,
you ascend to the throne as Elden
Lord alone, without a God
or living consort by your side.
Instead, your crumbling god is a vessel
for your Elden Ring, and not much more.
But previously, it seems an Elden
Lord was chosen by their God.
Chosen for their strength. Chosen
to sire a lineage.
cChosen
for their usefulness to their god's order.
So it was that Hoarah Loux was chosen to be
the Elden Lord
as the Age of the Erdtree began.
He defeated Marika's enemies,
He sired the Golden Lineage,
and then was discarded
in favor of Radagon --> an Elden Lord,
who betrayed Marika's enemies,
and sired more demigod children with her
before being shattered alongside his god.
And since we don't actually know
much about Placidusax's god,
we rely on Hoarah Loux, and Radagon,
and Marika as well to teach us
the things that we should assume
would have been
traditionally true about her.
So it is that Placidusax's
god likely chose him as overlord
because Placidusax was powerful,
politically expedient, loyal,
and/or perhaps a valid consort.
And speaking of Elden Lords
being consorts, it's
certainly possible that Placidusax
consorted with his god.
But I don't think that means that all or
any of the ancient dragons
would have been the result of that union.
In fact, as noted by ZullietheWitch,
the heads of Placidusax
are different, and are labeled
as "male" and "female" respectively.
So who's to say Placidusax
didn't spawn their own ancient dragons?
Whatever the case, the ancient dragons
were exceptionally loyal to their lord,
and multiple item descriptions state
that "the ancient dragons
who ruled the prehistoric era
before the Erdtree,
would protect their Lord
as a wall of living rock."
This is why "the shape of the dragon
has become symbolic
of all manner of protections."
And indeed, we commonly see dragons on
shields and on damage reduction talismans.
But even without his kin
laying down their lives to protect him,
Placidusax is intensely powerful
in their own right.
In fact, I'd say that Placidusax
was likely chosen as Elden Lord
for their strength in battle, and the
physical evidence of battle is all there.
Their form is severely scarred,
and even his heads
have been severed in unknown fights.
I think it's fair to speculate
that Placidusax
put their life on the line for their God.
Just as Elden Lords
would do for their gods in years to come,
and just as his ancient
dragons did for him.
But what exactly is an ancient dragon?
To help us distinguish between
all of the dragons in the game, it's
important to note that not all dragons
in Elden Ring are of the ancient variety.
Most are actually lesser
wyverns, like these.
Though they're all
descended from the same stock,
ancient dragons specifically
are characterized by their mastery of red
lightning, as well as their four wings,
four limbs, and stone scales.
These stone scales are perhaps
their most defining characteristic.
You would have found these stone scales
in your playthrough.
They would have been looted
as "Gravel Stones,"
which are said to be the scales
of the ancient dragons.
These Gravel Stones can be used to craft
Dragonwound Grease, a weapon
buff that increases the damage
you deal to dragons.
It reads "When the dragons were born from
their ancient kin, they lost their stone
scales, which can now
be used to cause them mortal harm."
Talk about insult to injury.
So just like in Dark Souls, it's
these stone scales
that gave the ancient dragons
their signature immortality.
And as further evidence for that fact,
consider the Dragon King's Cragblade,
which reveals that today's dual-winged,
two-legged dragons are considered "paltry"
and "mortal" --> again confirming that
the ancient dragons
were immortal by way of comparison.
But why are they immortal?
Well, the mechanism behind
this immortality is revealed
by the Ancient Dragon Smithing Stone's
description, which marks
it as a "golden Gravel Stone"
and a "scale of the Ancient Dragonlord."
Most importantly though,
it reads "This stone lightly
twists time."
Therefore, its Placidusax's very scales,
and likely also those of his kin
that have time twisting properties,
explaining the ancient dragons longevity.
It seems they're immune
to the effects of time.
This also explains
why Placidusax's Old Lord's Talisman
messes with time
"lengthening the duration of sorceries
and incantations"
in the hands of the Tarnished.
Most interesting, though, is that
the smithing stone goes on to state that
it allows for "the creation of a weapon
capable of slaying a god."
Presumably this is because of the scales
time twisting abilities,
which I theorize
might help to sort of undo the god
that gets smacked with this
from existing in the first place.
Maybe time undoes them in that way,
or perhaps
it speeds up their eventual irrelevancy
over time.
It's really fitting that a god would be
weak at a time and nothing else really.
Now, scales twisting time is one thing,
but all of Farum Azula seems to exist
outside of time,
To some extent. There is no day and night
cycle here, for example,
and this time twisting effect
is particularly strong in Placidusax's
arena, which you access by lying down
at the very edge of his storm.
In a way, you kind of become a part
of the environment here in this moment,
as the space you're lying in is actually
a shallow grave meant for entombment.
It's just missing a skeleton,
whereas the other graves have them.
And now that you're part of
Farum Azula itself,
time stops, then actually begins
to bring you backwards
in time with the repairing ruins
to Placidusax's forum,
where the dragon Lord once
dwelled eternally beyond time.
So time is extremely convoluted
in Placidusax's arena.
And I say this because it's here
in the "heart of the storm beyond time"
that you're able to use
an item called Miquella's Needle,
which is "one of the unalloyed gold needles
that Miquella crafted to ward away
the meddling of outer gods."
Now, currently
this needle is only a temporary solution.
It only wards off the outer
god's influence.
It doesn't cure
one of it, as Malenia is evidence
of indeed the final silver version
of the needle reveals that "the needle
is still as yet
unfinished and can only be used
in the heart of the storm beyond
time, said to be found in Farum Azula."
It's here alone that the needle does
finally function fully,
removing the entire influence of the outer
god in your body.
Miquella originally intended
to use this needle
to repel
the Outer God of Rot within his system.
But here, if you're locked into the Lord
of Frenzied Flame ending,
you can use the needle to "cheat fate"
and undo The Frenzy God's influence
instead.
This reveals that the final missing
component of the needle is time.
It just needs this final time
twisting effect to be complete.
So as with the smithing stones
we just mentioned,
perhaps you are inserting the needle
at a point
before the outer god's influence
existed upon you.
Or perhaps the gods are simply, again,
weak to time's effects.
I wonder if Miquella knew this.
I wonder if he knew that time twisting was
what was needed to complete the needle.
And I wonder if he even realized
that this is a place
you could come to do that. Anyway,
the one weird thing about Miquella's Needle
is that you can use it
in Placidusax's arena even though he's dead.
Raising the question, you know, hang on,
If it's Placidusax's scales
that twist time, why is it
time is being twisted here in a location
even without him and his scales present?
Now, I do have a theory
that might reconcile this issue.
Remember how I brought up that time
only starts moving backwards
when you lie down in a burial space
and become a part of the environment.
Well, my theory is that, what if it's
the landmass of Farum Azula itself
That also twists time?
I think it might be able to do this
because the landmass literally
has ancient dragons and the time-
twisting scales entombed within it.
The official art book reveals
a ton of these ancient dragons, and indeed,
ancient dragons can be found within
Farum Azula's geological stratum.
I asked dataminer
ZullietheWitch to take a closer
look at these assets, and she discovered
that there are two variants
of these entombed dragons
that show up here, here, here, and here.
So four dragons in total
that we can see, at least.
At first I thought that
these might represent
Placidusax's missing heads,
but the intact variant of the model
displays four wings and four legs,
meaning these were entire ancient dragons.
That said, they don't look entirely
like ancient dragons.
In fact, the heads are actually the same
as Placidusax's,
albeit
rendered in a lower level of detail.
So personally, given the information
I have, I believe that this suggests that
these entombed dragons might be
Placidusax's offspring or kin.
Perhaps even an older
generation of ancient dragon
entombed in a previous geological stratum
of Farum Azula's ancient history.
So it is that
I think you can argue that the landmass
of Farum Azula itself can twist time.
But additionally or alternatively
Farum Azula's storm itself
might represent this time
twisting Miquella's Needle does say that
it can only be used
in the "heart of the storm" in Farum Azula.
So perhaps Placidusax's golden scales
sort of "twisted" a storm into being,
And maybe that storm twists time,
irrespective
of whether Placidusax is alive or not.
Also, I really like the idea
that twisting storms
are a visual representation of the scales
that twist time,
because the scales do specifically use
the word twist in regards to time.
So the storm and these twisting hurricanes
are so perfect visually for that.
But as we move into the next chapter,
I want to point out
one more interesting thing
about these golden scales, and it's that
according to their item descriptions,
they're only "made" into ""stones
after being "polished,"
and thanks to their older item
description Text in version
1.0 of Elden Ring,
we know exactly who it was that polished
these stones in the first place.
They were "refined by sentient beasts
that regarded them as holy relics."
So it is that we arrive
at the beastmen of Farum Azula
who were the ancient
dragons clergymen, worshippers, and lessers.
There are a few types of beastmen
in Farum Azula,
but most wield their signature curved
sword, a weapon that is forged from dull
iron but is so well designed that
despite its weight, it's
"comparatively easy to wield for the damage
it delivers."
This skill in smithing seems to extend
to their throwing weapons as well,
which boomerang through the air towards
you like nothing else in The Lands
Between. As the Beastman's Cleaver itself
states, "It's clear
the beastmen possess knowledge
beyond human ken."
As you start to progress towards
the latter half of Farum Azula,
you'll start to be assailed
by red lightning wielded by the
beastmen clergy.
Some warriors even carry weapons
blessed with its effects.
This is significant
because red lightning is explicitly called
the "weapon wielded by the ancient dragons."
Lightning in Fromsoftware games
has always been a weapon of divinity,
and those that wielded are naturally
the blessed adherents of that divinity.
In this case,
the divines were the ancient dragons
who wielded this lightning
within the storms of Farum Azula.
So, for the beast men to wield it,
the art was probably taught to them.
For additional context,
one of the only other characters
who wields a weapon imbued with red
lightning
is Vyke,
a Tarnished beloved by an ancient dragon.
Indeed, certain beastmen
were, quote unquote, "chosen"
or blessed in a similar way, with the
Azula Beastman Spirit Ashes
stating that Farum Azula's giant
mausoleum was "guarded by chosen beastmen
who wield weapons clad in lightning."
For more evidence of the beastmen's
reverence of ancient dragons,
we can look to the five sites of grace
in Farum Azula
that mark different sections of the "Dragon
Temple. A sprawling place of worship
that features multiple statues of beast
clergymen bent in reverence towards
ancient dragon statues,
and the central part of the Dragon Temple
is this the place where you would have
fought the Godsskin Duo
an altar overshadowed
by an enormous dragon skeleton.
For reference, these skeletal remains
dwarf even Placidusax
and are matched only in size
by the Dragon Greyoll and the ancient dragon
Gransax, both of whom
we'll discuss a little bit later.
The Azula Beastman
Spirit Ashes states that Farum Azula
is "said to be the remains of a giant
mausoleum enshrining an ancient dragon"
and given this dragon's
prominent placement in the "Dragon Temple"
of all places, I actually think
the enshrined Dragon in question
might be this one, though
you could certainly make the argument
that the "enshrined ancient
dragon" was Placidusax instead.
But, regardless of exactly what
it's enshrining, Farum Azula really is
just a huge mausoleum with burial customs
literally around every corner.
Considering all the jars
in this place, one
such type of burial that comes to mind
is jar burial,
a practice documented in ancient
human cultures all across the globe.
Now, this practice would show up
more explicitly
later in Elden Ring's timeline
with the living Jars,
which are literally filled with
the interred remains of powerful warriors.
But beyond the powerful funerary imagery
in Farum Azula,
there's actually no explicit evidence
that I can find
that suggests actual entombment
within these jars.
In contrast, the Beastman's Jar
Shield is quite clear that "the beastmen
have always fired earthenware jars
for the express purpose of making shields."
The description comments
that these ways are "strange,"
and I feel like I can offer
a strange theory here.
We know that the beastmen
value golden stone scales, right?
And, we know that there are
literally ancient dragons
entombed within the earth of Farum Azula.
So what if the beastmen value
the dragon-infused earth for this reason?
Firing pots from this dragon earth
in an initial burial custom,
then breaking them to use
as sacred shields.
We established earlier
that the golden scaled ancient
dragons are a symbol of protection.
And considering these are earthenware
shields that are flecked
with the same golden hue as their scales,
I feel like this theory is alright.
It's the only way I can rationalize
making shields
out of pots
that are made out of earth, anyway.
Somewhat predictably,
the beastmen practice
entombment of their own species as well,
And I'm not just talking
about their gold adorned tombs.
I'm talking about the entombment
in the architecture itself as well.
The skeletal remains of the beastmen
frequently show up within
the architecture of Farum Azula itself.
This reminds me
of the historical practice of immurement,
which was this sort of horrific
form of capital punishment,
usually where the subject was entombed
in a structure while alive.
That said,
there are historical examples of
immurement
being more about human sacrifice.
A part of a grand burial ceremony
in some cultures,
and believed to make buildings
sturdier in others.
And I feel like it would have been
the beastmen
who built the architecture of Farum
Azula, not the dragons themselves.
It is structured to be a mausoleum
after all,
And since it's the beastmen who revere
the ancient dragons, it's naturally
the beastmen who would have occupied
the labor roles in society.
That said,
I guess humans also could have built it,
since humans are depicted in
the architectural reliefs of Farum Azula.
So, it stands to reason that humans
were a part of this culture as well,
even at this early prehistoric
period of time, which is kind of crazy
considering how much humans contrast
with the beastmen here.
As with a lot of the architecture
in Fromsoftware
games, I feel like
it would be a bit dishonest of me
not to mention
that these in particular are
reused assets also present in Bloodborne.
So, it's possible that Fromsoftware
didn't expect us to read into these assets
too hard.
But let's give them
the benefit of the doubt,
and assume that they at least
wanted to suggest
that there was a human presence
in Farum Azula once.
So not only were humans present,
but they were worthy of being enshrined.
Who were they?
Well, our biggest clues
about different types of humans
comes from origin text
in the character creation screen.
And, there are two human types
in particular
that I think might be a match
for the humans in these reliefs.
First are the Numen.
The Numen are "supposed descendants
of denizens of another world,"
and the Numen's Rune tells us
that "The Numen are said
to have come from outside the Lands
Between." Considering Farum Azula
experienced a cultural revolution
with the coming of the Greater Will
and the Elden Ring, which arrived upon
an extraterrestrial star.
I wouldn't be surprised if Numenoid
humans came along for the ride as well.
Alternatively, the character
creator reveals lore for "the stony
face of the people of the ancient dragons,
among whom life is typically short."
It certainly seems to be suggesting
that these humans are descended
from the ancient dragons.
I else would note their "stony" faces
or their short lives in contrast
to the ancients. As we'll discover later,
ancient dragons can turn into humans,
so perhaps they intermingled
at some point in the past
to create these humans.
That said, this is all just speculation
and a human presence on Farum Azula
is otherwise quite hard to process
considering
the beasts are clearly the legacy
of Farum Azula, for it was the beasts
who would gain intelligence and shape
the world around them, not humans.
Ancient historians have
long speculated
that it was the development of long
opposable thumbs that helped facilitate
early humans use of tools.
Similarly, in Elden Ring, having "five
fingers" is something to be celebrated,
as is revealed
by the Cinquedea,
a weapon of the Beast Clergyman.
This item description is one of those ones
that is just hugely significant
for the lore.
The name "Cinquedea" means "five fingers,"
and it visually shows
five skeletal fingers on the blade.
The item description goes on to state
that "the design celebrates a beast's
five fingers, symbolic of the intelligence
once granted upon their kind."
So, before there were beastmen,
there were simply beasts here,
and it was the bestowal of intelligence,
which is equated with having five fingers
that led to the beastmen.
This of course
begs the question who, or what,
bestowed intelligence upon the beastmen?
And luckily, it's a simple one to answer.
It was the Greater Will.
The Greater Will is all about fingers.
It speaks through the two fingers
it hates If you have three fingers,
it will tolerate four fingers,
but five is the amount to be celebrated,
or at least it was long ago.
And if this veneration of fingers
wasn't enough evidence for you
while the 1.0 version of the Cinquedea
literally states
that "it was the Greater Will
who granted the beast's intelligence."
So, that's that. The Greater Will clearly
also has a bit of a thing
for acting through beasts.
Just look at the final boss,
it's an "Elden Beast." One that the Greater
Will sent hurtling into the Lands Between
so that it could later
"become the Elden Ring."
And, in this prehistoric period,
the ancient dragons would be graced by
the Greater Will first with the beastmen
later being granted intelligence as well.
All the better
to revere the ancient dragons with
according to bestial incantations,
"stones were the first weapons
of the beasts who had gained intelligence,"
and "having gained intelligence,
the beasts must have felt
how their wildness
slipped away as civilization took hold."
Of course, this is yet
another example of where the Greater
Will takes away
wildness, or chaos, in favor of order.
It seems to care little
what form that order takes.
It only cares that some order takes hold,
preferably
taking hold with a full five fingered
fist.
In game
the five fingered Cinquedea
is wielded by Gurranq,
the Beast Clergyman.
According to the weapon
it is only "given to high ranking clergymen
of Farum Azula," marking Gurranq
as one of their number.
Presumably this means he is,
or was, a clergyman of the ancient
dragon faith before being "repurposed"
by the Greater Will,
becoming a shadow for Marika instead.
After all, when we encounter him in game,
the Age of the Ancient
Dragons has long passed, yet
he still achieves relevancy in this age,
in yet another subservient role,
as is common to all beasts.
Except this time it's to Marika,
and this time
he is a "Shadow of the Empyrean,"
which is a topic we should touch on next.
We first
meet Gurranq at
the Bestial Sanctum,
a place in Caelid
that bears a striking resemblance
to Farum Azula.
There's even a bridge down
the way called "Farum
Greatbridge," with a dragon
defending it, no less.
These are no mere ruins
that have fallen from the sky.
This architecture is intact and must
have been built for, and by, the beasts
at some point
after they received intelligence.
We'll get into that point
a little bit later,
but for now, let's focus on Gurranq.
We first learn about Gurranq
from his bestial incantations,
which are given to us
when we hand him deathroot.
They read "Long ago
Gurranq was a beast of such terrifying
ferocity that his former name
meant 'death of the demigods.'"
This former name in question was "Maliketh."
A new name to suit his new purpose,
which was to seal away
the Rune of Destined Death for Marika,
Who was his Empyrean.
So first he was Gurranq,
then, as the Age of the Ancient Dragons
ended and Marika
became a force in the world,
Gurranq became known as Maliketh instead,
who was, and I quote, "A shadow bound beast
given to his Empyrean," who was Marika.
Marika had one job for Maliketh,
and that was to "lock away Destined Death."
To a degree, he fails at this task
and a fragment of Destined
Death is stolen, becoming the deathroot
that spreads throughout the lands.
So it is that Gurranq
has returned to the Lands Between now,
trying desperately to scrape together
all the deathroot in the world.
The Beast Claw incantation talks
about his present identity,
as this spell "represents
the fury of Gurranq,
His bestial nature returned,
as much as it does his restless agitation."
But after realizing his mission
is impossible, Gurranq peaces out.
And then we're only able to find him
in one place alone... Farum Azula, where
he has ascended with a Draconic Tree
Sentinel as his defender.
Here, he sort of exists outside of time,
defending
what remains of Destined Death
within his very own flesh.
It's easy to get confused about when
Gurranq exists in the game, so apologies
for skipping over this topic quickly, but
this video is about dragons, after all.
And the main thing
I really want to get across here is just
how much the beasts have been repurposed
to suit the needs of the Greater Will.
First, it gave them intelligence, and then
they served the Ancient Dragons Order.
But then, when the ancient dragon's age
ended,
beasts like Gurranq were given new purpose,
commonly as shadow-bound entities
compelled to serve order once more.
Whatever form
their Empyreans dictated that order
should take. The Raging Wolf set states
that "according to the old legends,
wolves are the shadows of the Empyrean."
It's certainly possible that this legend
originated in Farum Azula.
There is, after all, a statue
that features
three wolves deferring to a human woman.
It might be a stretch to assume
that this is depicting
wolves as shadows of the Empyrean,
but I thought I'd mention it
at least. Again, in case you've forgotten,
an "Empyrean"
is basically one of the Greater
Will's candidates for godhood.
And in Marika and Ranni's case
at least, they were granted wolves
as their shadows.
Wolves, who evolved to be
"man's best friend" as they say,
are defined
as such because of their loyalty.
And as stated by the Beast Champion Helm
"the beasts, the eyes and ears covered
represent an oath:
See nothing, hear
nothing, doubt nothing, and carry
on along the path set in stone."
And, so it is
that Gurranq and Blaidd are wolves
completely loyal to their Empyreans,
dedicated to protecting their lords
just like the ancient dragons of old.
This loyalty to the Greater Will,
and also their Empyreans,
causes this fantastic tension
within these characters.
In the case of Gurranq,
he was loyal to Marika, but now lives
impatiently with this impossible task
of having to recover every piece of
deathroot.
And in the case of Blaidd, his loyalty
to Ranni eventually forces him
to betray the Two Fingers, in complete
defiance of the fate that he was born to.
Speaking of which, Blaidd is quite unique
from Gurranq.
Unlike Gurranq,
he has no apparent ties to Farum Azula.
After all, unlike Gurranq, he was "created"
to be Ranni's Empyrean and grew up
with her in a more modern age that was far
removed from Farum Azula's.
Perhaps this is why
Blaidd takes on a much more human form.
Blaidd was created
in a much more modern age
than the beasts of old,
so it seems the Two Fingers skipped
a lot of the history and simply created
Blaidd in a more half-man image.
Creating him from scratch
as opposed to his forebears.
The other beast worth mentioning
here is Serosh, the ethereal beast regent
given to Godfrey to weigh down
his ceaseless lust for battle.
Of course, Godfrey is Elden Lord,
not an Empyrean,
just so, Serosh is not a wolf,
but a lion. Like Gurranq,
he has a longer history, and according
to the Beastclaw, Greathammer
He was at one point a "Lord of Beasts"
with black nails
protruding from golden fur.
To quote the Champion Set, beasts
are "drawn to champions, and to lords,"
and this holds true for the beastmen
drawn to Serosh,
and in the future, it would hold true
for Serosh himself, a beast that "became
Lord Godfrey's regent," intended
to guide him and his golden lineage.
So, Serosh was drawn to Godfrey as well.
But no matter who the beasts were loyal
to, whether it was to the Beast Lords,
or to the ancient dragons,
or then, Elden Lords or Empyreans.
Throughout all of this, they were always
following a deeper loyalty.
A loyalty to the Greater
Will, and its ancient Elden ring.
This Elden Ring looks very different.
For one,
it appears to have many more circles,
many more great runes
than the modern Elden Ring.
Considering its placement in Farum Azula,
a place from long ago,
I speculate that this is an ancient
variant of the Elden Ring.
A depiction of it back
during the era of the ancient dragons.
What's more, this ancient Elden Ring
has what appear to be roots
snaking down and descending from it.
This is in contrast to the modern Elden
Ring, which has this latticed pattern
instead. The lattice pattern is most
commonly seen as a symbol of Radagon,
an "Elden Rune" that is visible
on his statues, and his scarseal as well.
I always thought that the latticed pattern
might represent
Radagon's efforts to sort of stitch
the Elden Ring back together
when it was shattered,
and we'll speculate on what the roots
might mean a little bit later as well.
As for why the Elden Ring looks different
though,
well it makes sense that the Elden Ring
would have changed throughout the ages.
We know the thing is malleable,
after all. There are examples of runes
being taken out of it,
and put back into it,
depending on the specific needs of the god
who acts as a vessel for its power,
or the needs of the Tarnished
who will become Elden Lord via great runes
or even via mending roots.
The vessel of the Elden Ring,
we know in the modern era is Marika.
She literally has the Elden Ring entombed
within her.
But back in the age before the Erdtree,
the Elden Ring
would have had a different vessel.
A different god.
And unfortunately, all we know about them
is that they abandoned Placidusax,
Who was their Elden Lord.
The Remembrance of the Dragonlord
reads "The Dragonlord
whose seat lies at the heart of the storm
beyond time
is said to have been Elden Lord in the age
before the Erdree.
Once his God was fled,
the lord continued to await its return."
I'm assuming that his god
had a female aspect,
considering all the other Empyreans
and gods in Elden Ring do.
So it is, that when we find Placidusax,
he is in a state of eternal
maidenlessness,
and who knows how long Placidusax
has been
waiting for his god to return.
In fact, one community theory
I love that
I've seen put forward a few times
is that Placidusax's
pose is similar to that of the Two Fingers
after you were rejected by the Erdtree.
In case you forgot,
it's at this stage that Enia says
the Two Fingers have taken up this pose
because they're busy
"consulting with the Greater Will."
Just so, the same might be true
of Placidusax, who has also been spurned
by his god and the Greater Will, and
is trying perhaps to commune with them.
To take this analogy
further, Placidusax has two heads now,
but data recently uncovered by Zulliethe-
Witch suggests that he once had five.
Not unlike how the Two Fingers assumedly
once came from a full five-fingered hand.
That said, the old Lord's
Talisman depicts Placidusax
with four heads.
To reconcile this contradiction,
maybe we can just think that he had
four heads when this talisman was made,
perhaps. Anyway, not a big deal.
What is a big deal is Placidusax's god,
who represents this huge blindspot for us
in Elden Ring's lore.
We don't know who they were,
we don't know what powers they had,
and we don't know when or why they left,
or what age
they really wanted to bring about.
As such, I'll be calling them
"The Nameless God"
from this point forwards.
Whoever they were,
all we know for certain is that they once
saw Placidusax as a valid Elden Lord,
So they might have been all about the Age
of the Ancient Dragons, once.
However,
I feel like it says more about this god
that they fled this age
and abandoned their loyal Elden Lord.
This reminds me a lot of what Marika did
to her Elden Lord, Godfrey.
Exiling and abandoning him after
he had won her wars,
and outlived his usefulness.
Though, at least with Godfrey,
Marika had a secret plan for her
Elden Lord and his Tarnished kin
to return.
On the other hand,
Placidusax was abandoned
and has waited for an eternity,
only to die at the hands of our Tarnished.
So whoever his god was,
I feel like they really
did abandon him entirely.
The Greater Will's
gods are the vessels of the Elden Ring,
and Placidusax's Nameless God jumping
ship with the Elden Ring would have
surely represented an enormous upheaval
to what became Crumbling Farum Azula.
Speaking of which,
I still haven't really explained
how it became "Crumbling" Farum Azula,
although many descriptions state
that Farum Azula has been crumbling
since time immemorial.
And, it's for this reason
that you can find tiny
ruin fragments, and enormous ones
too, scattered all over the Lands Between.
This is better explained by the
description of one such ruin fragment
which was "honed into a weapon"
called the Ruins Greatsword.
This is one of the legendary armaments.
"Originally rubble from a ruin
which fell from the sky,
the ruin it came from crumbled
when struck by a meteorite."
As such, this weapon harbors
its destructive power.
So meteorites with destructive power
are these purple spells in Elden Ring.
And indeed this weapons
skill is Waves of Destruction,
which manifests as purple energy.
So, a meteorite crashed into Farum Azula
and that meteorite was purple
and imbued the ruins
with a sort of gravitational magic.
But, beyond that, there's not really much
we know about this meteorite.
We don't even know if it struck Farum
Azula when it was a city on the ground,
lifting the city into the sky
with gravitational magic,
or if it struck Farum Azula
while it was already skybound,
crashing into the city
while it was in mid-air.
So much Farum Azula's
as history is hidden from us.
This meteorite
might even be the same meteorite
as others mentioned in Elden Ring's lore,
because lots of meteorites
have made landfall in the Lands
Between before.
Some brought the Onyx Lords,
a race of ancients
with skin of stone who rose to life
when a meteor struck.
A creature called
Astel may have brought himself down
on a meteorite and destroyed
an entire eternal city. A golden star
Even once bore the Elden Beast
and the Elden
Ring into the Lands
Between in the first place.
Thus,
you could speculate that any one of these,
or even a different one
entirely, laid waste to Farum Azula.
Again, you could even speculate that
it was this meteor
that imbued Farum Azula's ruins
with gravitational energy
lifting it into the sky,
not unlike how the earth in Limgrave
is lifted into the sky
after being hit by a meteorite.
And so, perhaps similarly, Farum Azula's
world was lifted higher into the sky,
twisting in place also thanks to the stone
scales of the ancient dragons.
Whatever the case, as Farum Azula crumbled
and twisted in the sky, ruined fragments
rained down upon the entire Lands
Between, some large and some small.
Incidentally, these ruined fragments "glow
with a faint light from within"
and are conducive to blessings from
the Two and Three Fingers respectively.
That's what Warming
Stones and Frenzy Flame Stones are.
They are pieces of rune
fragments imbued with power and light.
And this makes a lot of sense
because these ruins are a part
of the Royal City
that the Greater Will itself once graced.
So, naturally, parts of its ruins
are very conducive to the effects
of the Two and Three Fingers.
Anyway, we don't know many of the details
behind Farum Azula's ruin,
but whatever the case, it's
probably fair to say
that this meteorite dealt
an enormous blow to their culture.
It might have even coincided
with their god fleeing the city.
And whenever this nameless god did leave,
I think it's important to speculate
on where they went next.
After the Age of the
Dragonlord,
the Age of the Erdtree began.
But before the Age of the Erdtree
began, we learned that there was first
a "crucible of life," a "primordial crucible,
where all life was once
blended together." According to
Siluria's Crucible Tree Helm
this crucible was "the primordial form
of the Erdtree."
a "manifestation of the Erdtree's
primal vital energies."
So, Over the next few minutes,
I'm going to try and argue that
The Crucible became rooted
quite literally, quite physically,
in the great tree roots
that we find underneath the Lands Between.
I don't think it's a coincidence
that the ancient Elden Ring of Farum Azula
is burgeoning with roots
and after Farum Azula's age ended
and it's god absconded with an Elden Ring
that is burgeoning with roots.
I don't think it's a coincidence
that a primordial crucible
gave way to a great tree
that would dominate the Lands Between.
I think the Elden Ring
physically left Farum Azula.
I think that led to the crucible,
which led to great tree
roots, which led to the Erdtree growing.
The Elden Ring is,
after all, the source of the Erdtree,
and this should have been true
for the ancient Elden Ring as well,
which would have buffed this tree.
As an additional piece
of evidence that the Elden Ring
is at the source of the Erdtree,
we can look to the engraving
on the stone door
of the Erdtree itself,
which shows the Elden Ring literally
at the roots of the Erdtree.
Its source below the surface.
Perhaps the Elden Ring
wasn't rooted in the earth
while Farum Azula
was floating up in the sky.
But eventually it seems
it would be. according
to the Gilded Greatshield and
Ordovis's Greatsword
the color of the Erdtree's
primordial crucible was red.
Or perhaps, more accurately,
red tinged with gold.
"The red tinge in the gold coat mirrors
the primordial matter
that became the Erdtree.
The color of Homeward yearning.
Its red tint exemplifies
the nature of primordial gold,
said to be close in nature to life itself."
This color is also seen in Root
Resin, a secretion
from roots that were once connected
to the great tree.
These two items, taken together, tie
the red of the crucible to great tree
roots quite well.
And if that wasn't enough, Crucible Knight
Siluria
spends her exile amidst
these roots, with a spear and a helm
that have "great tree ornamentation"
that is "modeled on the crucible."
I've seen people speculate
that the crucible isn't a physical place
and that it was just
a crucible of competition instead,
where different creatures
battled against each other.
And I think this misconception
might be due to the original description
of the Old Fang in version
1.0 of Elden Ring,
which reads "In times long past,
life was a crucible of competition."
However, the item description was quickly
patched to remove
all mention of competition,
and the patch description instead suggests
that multiple overlapping fangs might be
"a vestige of the primordial crucible."
So considering this updated description
and all of the color
and mention of primordial matter,
I think fromsoft are certainly trying
to suggest that the crucible
had a real physicality to it.
And the crucible has long
been a topic plagued by confusing
and perhaps mistranslated item
descriptions.
Take the aspects of the crucible
which say that the crucible
was once a place where "all life was once
blended together."
The Japanese instead clarifies
that "once, life was blended together,"
which to me suggests
the crucible was a blending
of existing life in the Lands Between,
rather than a source of all life.
And I think there's more evidence
that this ancient Elden Ring of Farum Azula
was already kind of laying the groundwork
for the crucible.
For example,
we know from The Omen and Misbegotten
that creatures of the Crucible
are characterized by chaotic growth
considered aspects of devolution
in the modern era.
These are aspects of wings, horns,
scales, feathers, and fangs
just so Placidusax actually
has tons of random
fang growths around their maw,
And later dragons even sprout feathers,
Another aspect of devolution.
But if that wasn't enough, remember,
the dragon's lightning is red
tinted with gold as well,
which is the same color
of the primordial crucible,
as we just discussed.
Thus, I think it's safe to say
that the color and other aspects
of the primordial crucible were already
kind of present in the ancient dragons,
the oldest of those graced
by the Elden Ring that we know of.
So with that, we've essentially laid
the groundwork for a theory
that I'd like to shout out from Lowkey,
who is one of Fromsoftware
as most dedicated theory crafters.
In this theory, he speculates on
the identity of the Dragonlords fled god.
And I think this theory is special
because it manages to reconcile
a couple of major loose ends in the game's
lore along the way.
As the theory goes,
the Erdtree was created
as a byproduct
of the Nameless God's death.
Lowkey's
initial reasoning is that after we die,
runes are left behind in our wake,
manifesting as small golden saplings.
Therefore, since the Elden Ring itself
is made up of a gargantuan
amount of runes, surely the Elden Ring
would sprout an enormous tree
if the god-vessel carrying it were to die.
One thing I'll add to this theory
is that our golden saplings
only remain so
if the mass of runes is not claimed.
Just so, if no one knew
that the Nameless God had died,
perhaps the Elden Ring's
mass of runes was left to its own devices
to grow, as Lowkey posits, as a resilient
protective vessel, a "firmly rooted" tree.
"That welcometh no man"
and indeed the Nameless God did flee.
Not even telling her Elden
Lord Placidusax where they had gone.
Thus, their runes might have gone
unclaimed.
Directly
below the Erdtree are the Deeproot Depths
where the Erdtree
might have once been planted, so to speak.
And one of the lesser known paths along
the routes here leads to this wall,
an illusory wall that reveals
the Cathedral of the Forsaken,
The Frenzied Merchants
and the Three Fingers of Frenzy.
One of the strangest items down
here is the Fingerprint Stone Shield,
which is, and I quote,
"part of the tomb of an ancient god."
Its with an "intricately carved
fingerprint design."
And these imprints are "said to be the very
seeds from which frenzy first sprouted."
Now, at first glance, you'd think
that the ancient god in question
here would be the Three Fingers who marked
this great stone slab with fingerprints.
And while I admit, this stone
grave could be for the "Outer
God of Frenzied Flame"
which manifests as the Three Fingers
who are imprisoned down here,
I much prefer the theory that this stone
slab was the tomb of a different
ancient god, one
that was found and desecrated
by the Three Fingers
with their fingerprints, just as they
desecrate the world
with fingerprints in their ending.
And that's exactly what Lowkey's theory
proposes, that the Three Fingers
desecrated a stone
tomb of the Nameless God, Placidusax's
queen,
who had her final moments in this place.
The Nameless God can also be used
to reconcile another lore gap
in Elden Ring,
which is the identity of the corpse that
makes up the Fingerslayer Blade.
The Fingerslayer Blade is "a blade
said to have been borne of a corpse,"
"said to be able to harm
the Greater Will and its vassals."
The Two Fingers.
The shape of this blade
featuring the arms of a corpse
as a cross guard
and culminating in a double helix,
it bears a striking resemblance
to the Sacred Relic sword,
a weapon wrenched
from the corpse of Radagon/Marika.
The Sacred Relic Sword is, and I quote,
"wrought from the remains of a god
who should have lived a life eternal."
The similarities
between the Sacred Relic Sword
and the Fingerslayer Blade mean
that they must have shared a source.
Not just a corpse,
but the corpse of a god.
We know where the Sacred
Relic Sword comes from,
it comes from Radagon and Marika.
But then where does the Fingerslayer
blade come from?
If it's wrought from a god, it's
a nameless god,
as far as we know.
So it is that Lowekey concludes that the Nox
who made a hidden treasure of the blade,
may have recovered
the corpse of Placidusax's Queen,
The Nameless God, to wield as a weapon
that could harm the greater will.
So I like these theories,
to say the least.
They neatly tie up and reconcile
a bunch of loose ends,
and that makes these theories
really satisfying to believe.
It's nice to have
an explanation for which god
the Fingerslayer Blade was talking about
and which ancient god the Fingerprint
Stone Shield was talking about.
Special thanks to Lowkey for this.
You can find more of his stuff
in the description, and I
highly recommend
you seek it out.
However, I should probably stress
that this is still all speculation.
The circumstantial evidence
is really strong.
Yes, but sometimes Fromsoftware leaves
these sorts of loose ends in the lore
to be tied up by characters
that they've yet to introduce.
And until DLC drops, I think it's wise
to take this theory with a grain of salt.
But damn, you know, salt makes any meal
taste a little bit better, doesn't it?
So it is that the Nameless God of
Farum Azula might have become the Nox's
Fingerslayer Blade,
a weapon they clearly brought about
in order to harm the Greater Will,
which had banished them deep underground
beneath the false night sky.
You can learn more about that
in this video. Here
They live in eternal anticipation of the
coming age of stars and their leige.
Who would be a Lord of Night.
These folk become obsessed
with artificial imitation of life
above ground, all likely
created in service of their goal,
which was to strike back
at the Greater Will.
So it was that
the Mimic Tears were created.
These are beings of quicksilver
that were "the result
of an attempt by the Eternal City
to forge a Lord."
These silver drops of dew,
not unlike the Erdtree's drops of dew,
They also birthed the albinaurics,
who are artificial
lifeforms untouched by the Erdtree's
grace.
But the Nox also looked further back
in time for inspiration,
Apparently, and they attempted
to bring ancient dragons into being.
So it is that the Dragonkin Soldiers
"were born in the Eternal City,
where they knew
no true sky, nor true lightning."
Their name includes the word "soldier"
and they even have evidence of clothing
and armor upon them, again
revealing that these creatures
were created with the intention
to fight back against Order.
But these Dragonkin experiments
went about as well as copying dragons
usually does in Fromsoftware games,
which is to say
the experiments were a failure.
The main reason they were considered
failures
was that these dragonkin
were not immortal, as the Nox had hoped.
The weapons read
"Alas, the dragon console
just never attained immortality
and perished as decrepit, pale
imitations of their skyborn kin."
But the Nox had the right idea.
At the very least,
it seems they had identified the source
of the ancient dragon's immortality,
their stone scales.
They just failed to
implement that source.
Case in point: the Dragonscale Blade
is made by "sharpening a Gravel Stone scale
thought to be the source of dragon
immortality."
This blades skill is "Ice Lightning Sword,"
which wreathes the blade in the
Dragonkin's signature ice lightning.
And, you know, even though the dragonkin
were born mortal and crippled,
they did at least manage
to manifest lightning,
which is a feat that the mortal dragons,
who were actually the Ancient
Dragon's kin, never accomplished.
On your
way through Caelid, you would have run
past Greyll, a mortal dragon
who clearly owes their namesake to Greyoll,
a veritable mountain found further down
the way where she lies dying,
surrounded by her children
on her deathbed.
But these aren't her only children.
According to Greyoll's
Roar "Greyoll was the mother of all
dragons, dwarfing all who stood before her
like a looming mountain."
To be clear, I seriously doubt this means
that she's the mother of the Ancient
Dragons, considering she has two wings,
two legs, and no stone scales.
No. Instead, she would specifically be
the mother of the two-
winged dragons that you see
widely across the Lands Between.
Indeed, the Japanese specifies
that she's more
of a "great mother of dragons"
rather than being mother of all dragons.
So, if we take that premise to be true,
that means that the fire-breathing
dragons,
the ice dragons, the rot-and-glintstone
corrupted dragons, all of them
trace their ancestry back to Greyoll.
These are the "wyverns" contrasting
with the true four legged "dragons",
which is the same dynamic
that Dark Souls had as well.
And just like in Dark Souls,
Elden Ring's dragons have a tendency
to take on aspects of their environment
in lieu of their stone scales.
There are ice dragons, there are
Glintstone dragons, all of that.
But the one element that these dragons
didn't master, though, is lightning,
red lightning that remains exclusive
to their ancient ancestors.
Earlier, we talked about how lightning
has heavenly connotations,
and it makes sense
that this lightning would be lost to
these lesser dragons
who were born in a time long after
the ancient dragons had sort of lost
the favor of the Greater Will.
These modern dragons are now easily
wounded by the stone scales
that they've lost. These stone scales,
once removed are called Gravel Stones,
and these are "compound stones
that are found
in lands once beset by ancient dragons."
For the most part, these Gravel Stones
are looted upon the Altus Plateau
and surrounds, which makes sense
because this is the territory of Leyndell,
the city that the ancient dragons
would eventually assault.
So, of course,
this is where their scales would be found.
But interestingly, the only other place
where gravel stones are found is Caelid.
And that's curious
because Caelid is literally at the opposite
end of the Lands Between.
one set of gravel stones I found here,
and here, suggesting that at some point
the ancient dragon's progenitors to Greyoll
were in Caelid as well.
And this fact is supported by other
environmental evidence in the area.
Again, the Bestial Sanctum and Farum
Great Bridge are in Caelid,
two cultural landmarks of Farum Azula
that are architecturally intact
despite the crumbling city's
current state.
These weren't just ruins
that fell from the sky.
These were built.
They are a grounded connection
to what we now know as a sky city.
While I guess we can't rule out
the possibility that Farum
Azula was always in the sky and later
built architecture on the ground here.
It seems way more natural to assume
that the city was originally built
on the ground where they would have been
the materials to build it,
and that it was then lifted into the sky
at some point in the future.
As for the mechanism behind Farum Azula
becoming skybound,
I feel like there are two options.
Earlier we talked about how the Ruins
Greatsword is a piece of Farum Azula
infused with gravitational magic
thanks to the meteor that struck the city.
Thus, my first theory is that Farum
Azula might have become skybound
in the instant that the meteor struck,
floating upward as it was destroyed.
Alternatively, or additionally
I guess, it could be some manifestation
of the storm
that brought Farum Azula into the sky.
We've talked about how Placidusax
might have had power over this storm,
evidenced by his golden
time-twisting scales.
Not to mention you turn into a storm cloud
when you channel Placidusax's
weapons skill.
So perhaps Placidusax,
or the ancient dragons,
whipped Farum Azula into the skies
as some measure of protection,
and once it was up there,
that gravitational meteor
could have come into play,
smashing the city into pieces on its way
down to the Lands
Between, scattering ruins far and wide.
At any rate, I'm glad there's
evidence of Farum Azula here in Caelid,
and that's because this fact merges
so well with the lore of Greyoll.
Again,
Greyoll is the mother of the modern dragons,
and thus is the oldest modern dragon
that we know of
who lost their stone scales.
And since she's in Caelid, it was likely
from here that all dragons spread.
So, I'm glad the environment supports
this lore
with its intact Farum Azula architecture
and with the leftover Gravel Stones
of the ancient dragons as well,
because it seems like the ancient dragons
made landfall here
long ago,
and started a culture in Farum Azula,
leaving Greyoll behind eventually
as their land bound legacy.
And there are two other ancient dragons
in the vicinity to help support
this claim as well.
These ancient dragons appear here in
Limgrave and here in Caelid,
both dead at the sites of Dragon
Communion.
The ancient dragons are immortal,
but they can still be killed.
As you know. Though, we can only really
speculate on what killed these two.
But back to Greyoll.
Despite being a modern dragon,
Greyoll is large. Larger
than any other dragon of the time,
even Placidusax.
In fact, the only thing that comes to her
in size are Gransax,
and the bones of the dragon in Farum Azula
as Dragon Temple,
which Zullie has thankfully placed
alongside Greyoll for me.
They're both very similar in size,
which made me think that
maybe they could have been mates
at some point.
Though of course that's just speculation.
And in the end we don't even know why
Greyoll lost all of her stone scales,
passing this trait
to all of her descendants.
Perhaps it was nothing more than a random
birth defect.
Which reminds me, Seath's loss of stone
scales was never really explained either.
Yet, he also found himself apart
from his ancient kin all the same.
Perhaps this is why Greyoll found herself
in the Lands Between.
Was this a place of exile?
Maybe a place to die?
Her region is called Dragonbarrow
after all,
And if you've read Lord of the Rings,
for example, you might take the meaning
the word barrow to mean burial mounds,
referring
to ancient burial places that are covered
with large mounds of earth.
Perhaps the dragonbarrow was a place
for these newly mortal dragons to die,
and Greyoll herself is indeed
now finally dying.
The Scarlet Rot has blighted Caelid
and the dragonbarrow.
And this is presumably why,
when we encounter her,
she's already lost a lot of her health
and she can't fight back,
nor even lift herself off the ground.
Her dying roars rally her kin around her.
But they cannot save their mother.
This level one Tarnished.
Just watch this sick YouTube
guide on how to get 50,000
free runes at the start of the game,
and nothing will stand in their way.
Now, we previously established Caelid
and Greyoll as a sort of origin point
for the modern dragons.
So after them in the timeline,
I think it's the ice dragons
that would have shown up
as the first major variant.
According to Borealis's Mist,
the ice dragons were once
lords of the mountain tops.
Perhaps these dragons wish to be as close
as possible to the heavens
from which their ancestors descended.
After all,
we do see the modern dragons flying
all around Farum Azula,
though they never make landfall.
So, the mountain tops
might have been the next best thing
as a home for the mortal dragons.
After all, the Sword of Night
and Flame claims
that the mountain tops
"nearly touched the sky."
Anyway, Borealis's Mist goes on to reveal
that the ice dragons
were lords here at a very early point
in the Lands Between's history.
As shortly after we know
that they were chased from the peak
by the fire giants
who also appeared at a very early point
and who claimed the mountaintops
henceforth.
So, for the ice dragons to be here,
you'd think, surely
they must have migrated here from Caelid.
Now, we previously established Caelid
as an origin point
for these modern dragons.
So for the ice dragons to be here,
surely they must have initially migrated
here from Caelid.
Obviously, they could have just flown
from Caelid to the icy mountaintops.
But I remember early theories
that posited that a land bridge
might have once existed between Caelid
and the mountaintops,
and that certainly would have helped
with their migration.
As the theory goes, Caelid in the
mountaintops are almost exclusively
where you'll find the monstrous
crows, the giant dogs,
and most notably,
the remains of the giants.
These don't really appear anywhere else,
and it seems way
more likely to think
that there was once a land bridge here.
Rather than thinking
that they took long way
round the lands between on foot.
what happened to this landmass is unclear,
but the Lands Between itself
has experienced
many other
geographical upheavals in the past,
and losing a landmass to a meteor
or whatnot might also explain
the divergent evolution of the ice dragons
compared to their fire-breathing kin.
Also established in the mountaintops
around this time were the astrologists
who "preceded
the sorcerers,
established themselves in mountaintops
that nearly touched the sky, and considered
the fire giants their neighbors."
This description comes to us
from the Sword of Night and Flame,
an heirloom of the Carian Royal Family,
which is headed by Rennala.
Rennala was a prominent astrologer,
and thus has links to the Mountaintops
of the Giants.
It might be a stretch to say
that she was actually there
in the mountaintops all years ago, but
she did have an oathsworn giant
and an oathsworn dragon
that can be summoned to fight for her.
So I feel like it's safe to say that she's
connected to the place
at least. At any rate,
eventually the fire giants would chase
the ice dragons from the peak
and claim it for their own.
Then in turn,
the Zamor, An icy race of warriors
would ally with the Golden Order
and oust the fire giants.
This is incidental,
but later in the timeline, a character
called the "Snowy Crone" pops up.
She's an old witch associated with Caria
who wielded snowy magics
that you could argue
would have been derived from the Zamor's
icy mountaintops.
The Zamor are
After all the only other beings
that could use cold sorceries,
so perhaps she learned it from them.
This snowy crone eventually imparted
her cold sorceries
to Ranni, and Ranni has clearly taken
on such frost magics
as a big part of her sorcerous identity.
Now, a couple of dragons actually had
a habit of eating glintstone sorcerers.
And it was from this diet
that they were corrupted,
not unlike the other dragons
who took on aspects of their environment.
One of these dragons was Smarag
fought here,
whose Glintstone Breath incantation reads
"Smarag was a devourer of sorcerers, and
over time, his body became corrupted
by their Glintstones."
Another such dragon is fought here
defending Ranni
in both of her major quest locations.
This is Adula, and she drops a cold-
infused sorcery
that is representative of her knighthood.
And it reads "Adula,
a devourer of sorcerers, was bested by Ranni
and subsequently
swore a knightly oath to her Dark Moon."
This suggests conflict
between the early sorcerers and dragons,
and this tendency for there
to be conflict helps to explain why
Rennala might have gained an oathsworn
dragon out of these conflicts.
And just like her mother before her, Ranni
also had an oathsworn dragon of her own,
Adula. Adula reveals to us
the mechanism behind this oath.
Ranni bested Adula in battle,
perhaps earning Adula's loyalty
and respect.
A trend that actually continues later on
with some other ancient dragons
that would attack Leyndell,
but we'll get into that soon.
The living ice dragon we meet is Borealis,
the Freezing Fog
who remains upon the mountaintops.
And yet the item most closely associated
with him
is actually found all the way back
in the Temple Quarter of Liurnia.
It is the Icerind Hatchet,
and its description reads
"A hatchet with a frost-coated blade.
One of several gifts
given by Castle Sol in the distant
north. Known as 'freezing fog,'
The blade is thought to be a dragon's
scale."
Indeed,
this is the dragon scale of Borealis,
because just as the scale
is known as "freezing fog,"
Borealis also has the woods "freezing fog"
As his namesake, when you fight him.
Apparently this scale was retrieved
by Borealis's neighbors at Castle Sol,
who then gave it as a gift,
presumably to the Liurnians,
since it is found near
their temple quarter.
Obviously such a gift
would have been given
to facilitate relations
between the two lands.
And, as we established earlier with
sorcerers like the Snow Witch and Rennala,
there is grounds to believe that these
two places would have had a connection
the past.
These days, though,
Castle Sol is currently
still a mystery to us.
And without knowing their political
alignments, it's hard to know for sure
why they gifted Liurnia with the scale
and other gifts as well.
That said, there is a phantom in Castle Sol
who hails Lord Miquella in his dialog.
Thus, it's possible
that Miquella was Lord of Castle Sol
and that Miquella
was giving gifts to Liurnia,
and there is evidence that Miquella
had friendly relations with the Carians,
at least. Most notably in version
1.0 of Elden Ring.
Loretta's armor instead belonged to cut
enemies called "Arbor Sentinels,"
who served Miquella,
but who actually hailed from Raya Lucaria.
To quote the cut description,
"these enchanted knights once
belonged to the Carian royal family,
but were later gifted to Miquella."
Thus, perhaps Miquella, potential
Lord of Castle Sol,
gifted the Raya Lucarians the
Icerind hatchet, and several other gifts
besides,
in return for all the knights
that he had gained from them.
Again, this is all just speculation,
but this is the best theory
I've got on the relationship
between these two lands
and why the Icerind
Hatchet is found in Liurnia
on the same plateau as Castle
Sol is the cave of the Forlorn.
And it's a unique little cave
guarded by a Great Wyrm
Theodorix.
Theodorix is a Magma Wyrm,
A land-bound dragon, that looks more like
a giant lizard than a dragon.
He's in this form
thanks to the act of "Dragon Communion,"
a primal ritual that involves consuming
a dragon's heart to become a dragon.
Didn't work out so well for him,
but his scalesword
at least resembles a dragon's jaw.
And the weapon suggests that Dragon
Communion is "a grave transgression,"
For which the Magma Wyrms
were "cursed to crawl the earth
upon their bellies,
shadows of their former selves."
If they were cursed to be this way
by any entity, I'd suggest
it was the Greater Will who we know
favored the ancient dragons long ago.
And to be clear, only the English
description says they were cursed
The Japanese description is nowhere near
as damning,
simply saying that the heroes have "erred"
and that "their land-crawling
form is the end result."
To me, it sounds more like
these people were simply fools
to think that they could achieve
such a metamorphosis.
It goes against the rules of nature,
especially if you're
trying to transform
into a being like an ancient dragon,
who were graced by the Greater
Will in a bygone age.
And, I think more than it being a curse,
I think this is more of an example
of hubris backfiring
for each and every one of these partakers
of Dragon Communion.
The Magma Wyrm's scalesword states
that "these land bound
dragons were once human heroes."
But that's only half true for Theodorix,
who was a hero, but who wasn't human.
He was actually a troll.
His incantation Theodorix's Magma
states "The name of the ancient
troll warrior Theodorix lives on -
as a hero of the War against the Giants."
Actually,
maybe his troll heritage explains why
his Magma Wyrm form is so much tougher
than the others.
It has so much HP that, fun fact,
you can actually lure a land octopus
to help you with this fight instead,
and I think that's the intended way
because this guy is tough.
What's also fascinating about
this guy is that he was specifically
a hero of the War against the Giants,
a battle that many of his fellow trolls
participated in,
betraying their giant ancestors
and fighting alongside the Golden Order.
Now, I assume Theodorix was still troll
at this stage and not a Magma Wyrm,
but whatever the case,
you could definitely speculate that he is
still loyal to the Golden Order, even now,
even here after his metamorphosis.
I argue this because of his placement
outside the Cave of the Forlorn,
which has an end boss
wielding a legendary armament,
The Golden Order Greatsword.
One of Radagon's own weapons.
The Leonine Misbegotten themselves
are curious as well,
with internal files
calling them children of Radagon.
But that's a whole
'nother topic. Unique to this cave also
is that right inside
there's a fire-breathing dragon, dead
and half entombed within the ice.
For this type of dragon
to be preserved in this place
might support
what I speculated on earlier,
which is that Greyoll's fire-breathing
children must have come up here
to settle on the peaks
before becoming ice dragons.
And it might also support the theory
that Rennala acquired
an oathsworn fire-breathing dragon
just like this one,
early in the days when they settled here
alongside the astrologers.
Or maybe it's just here
because a dragon-hunter is right outside.
And I say dragon-hunter
because even though the dragon-hearted
like Theodorix aspire to
become dragons by consuming their hearts,
that doesn't mean that they respected
their lives.
A phantom can even be found saying,
"I'm dry...
Dry as a bone. fool dragon.
Surrender your strength.
Let me feast on your heart."
As for the hearts
of these dragons themselves,
they are riddled with Gravel Stone.
You'll recall Gravel Stones
with the scales of the ancient dragons,
making it somewhat ironic that
the mortal dragons actually do have these
same scales just within their hearts,
not on their flesh.
As such, their hearts,
which are clearly imbued with some ancient
dragon immortality, are still alive
and beating, according to the description.
And so, when you consume these hearts
in what is absolutely
a sacrificial ritual,
especially considering
the heart is still alive,
you're actually consuming Gravel Stone,
ingesting the key
components of the ancient dragons via
the hearts of their mortal kin.
It's pretty metal. Indeed,
when you partake in dragon communion
with the heart at the Dragon Communion
Altars, you're doing so right in front
a dead ancient dragon,
not in front of a mortal one.
Thus you really are striving to be like
the ancients.
Churches were built
upon the corpses of these undying beings
who became, likely unwilling,
conduits for countless dragon-hearted
who wished
to channel the power of dragons.
Finally, the Dragon Communion Seal.
It's formless
because it's made of dragon blood.
And even though it's a seal," Dragon
Communion is too primal
in nature for the term 'incantation'
to be appropriate."
Thus, "this seal scales incantations
with one's arcane attribute."
So yeah, it's no wonder
that all of the dragon-hearted
are considered to be so depraved.
[Yura] You must not forget, though,
those who partake in Dragon Communion
will one day shed humanity. Their hunger
for dragon,
their yearning
only worsens. Until the floodgates burst,
unleashing eternal torment.
The strength of a mighty dragon.
Magnificent,
but deadly.
It's no surprise
that drug and communion is ruinous.
This is Yura, who you first
meet in Limgrave
and nearby beside the Dragon-Burnt Ruins
is the mortal Dragon Agheel.
Agheel frequents this place,
coming to burn the mindless nobles
and their effigies here,
which is exactly what the nobles want.
After death, most in the Lands
Between crave a proper Erdtree burial.
But now, in lieu of that perhaps,
"The dead gazed at the skies
over the lakes of Limgrave,
praying that the dragon's flames
would burn them to ash."
They want this kind of release from life.
If you get Yura to assist you
in taking out Agheel,
then it's possible to get him to say this:
[Yura] That was my first dragon hunt
in quite some time.
Paired up with a hot-head like you
it was just like old times."
So, Yura was previously
a dragon hunter,
which helps to explain his familiarity
with communion.
And since being paired up with a hot-head
like you was just like old times.
That means he must have
once had a companion.
The most likely candidate for
this is Eleonora,
a Drake Knight that Yura tracks
all the to the Altus Plateau,
only to plead with them
on a very personal level.
1:24:28:00 --> 1:24:15:20
[Yura] Please, please, Eleonora, yield to
the cessblood no longer.
1:24:15:30 --> 1:24:25:00
Do not stain the immaculacy of your
sword, your flesh... your fire.
The precious little
we know about Eleanora stems mostly
from her Drake Knight Armor,
which is crafted from Dragon
wing membranes and "Features the spoils
of a dragon catch, as an emblem of pride
as both dragon hunter
and partaker of communion."
"from birth, drake knights speak not a word.
They spend their lives
pursuing the strength of dragons
for its sublime
beauty and inspiration of all."
Therefore, while the drake knights
have more reverence of dragons,
they are still partakers of communion.
Thus, as they consume more hearts,
their eyes become yellow and slitted,
and inevitably they have a fate
waiting for them as a Magma Wyrm.
So, given all you've heard about communion,
is it really any surprise
that there would be a dragon named
the "Dragon Communion Revenger?"
This is Ekzykes, who guards
the decrepit temple of communion in Caelid,
attempting to prevent this abhorrent
act of dragon communion
via sheer will and hatred.
For Ekzykes
has had the misfortune of taking
on the scarlet rot as his aspect,
something that has clearly taken
a toll on him.
But according to his incantation,
"Ekzykes, Dragon Communion Revenger,
did not forget his hatred
even as he succumbed to the scarlet rot."
So Ekzykes, at
least has a very good reason for attacking
you as he's preventing access
to the nearby Altar of Dragon Communion.
But, speaking of dragons who attack humans,
let's turn our attention
to the ancient dragons who would one day
attack the city of Leyndell.
These ancient dragons attacked
with all their might,
bringing with them Gransax,
an ancient dragon
who is the largest dragon in the game,
who "rained calamity down
upon the Royal Capital"
with such force that this marks
the "only time in historical record
that Leyndell's walls" had fallen.
Thus began Leyndell's
war against the ancient dragons.
It's hard to know
for sure
why the ancient dragons attacked Leyndell.
If you want to go full tinfoil hat
and tie it to our earlier speculations,
then you might say that it's
because they finally realized
their god had fled here
and become the Erdtree or something,
but that might be stretching it.
That said, they probably did come here
because of the Erdtree.
After all, according to the Protection
of the Erdtree incantations
"in the beginning,
everything was in opposition
to the Erdtree," and the ancient dragons
were probably no exception.
So it was that the ancient dragons
fell upon Leyndell. Their forces
consisting of at least three dragons
that we know of.
Lansseax, and her red lightning glaive.
Fortissax,
and his twin pillars of Red Lightning.
and Gransax, a gargantuan dragon
wielding a physical weapon
actually, a decision
that seems unique to them.
This is the Bolt of Gransax, a weapon
that's actually mirrored
in Placidusax's fight against us
here.
It's unclear
whether Placidusax is echoing
Gransax
or if Gransax is echoing Placidusax.
But the fact that Gransax shares
a weapon with Placidusax
and the fact that Gransax is so large
certainly makes me think
that Gransax is the closest thing
the ancient dragons
might have had to a lord.
At the time of their attack upon Leyndell,
At any rate. But, this weapon
would eventually fall from their grasp
as the great Gransax was slain,
their stone body and weapon
becoming this permanent landmark
within Leyndell's walls.
According to Lightning Spears
description, "Godwyn the Golden defeated
the ancient dragon Fortissax, known
as the mightiest Boulderstone."
Assumedly, Godwyn could have executed
Fortissax here, or perhaps compelled
Fortissax to swear an oath to him,
just like Rennala and Ranni once did.
but instead, he befriended his fallen foe,
and as a result, for the sex
would be loyal.
So loyal that Fortissax
would eventually go beyond
to fight against the death
that would take his companion.
Becoming a lichdragon,
his aspect afflicted with death itself.
So to recap, when Godwyn was murdered
on the Night of Black Knives,
the Rune of Death was carved
into his being, destroying his soul,
but not his body.
And so it was that his body spawned
deathroot,
fragments of the Rune of Death
that spreads its influence
throughout the Lands
Between spawning the visage
of the Prince of Death,
who was Godwyn, in its wake.
And while Godwyn does seem like a lost
cause
Fortissax fought against the death
within him nonetheless.
So it is that Fortissax occupies
a deathbed dream within his friend,
fighting this impossible fight against the
corrupting influence of the Rune of Death,
which has now corrupted Fortissax.
But I still don't think that Fortissax
has been completely corrupted.
When you fight against Fortissax here,
you actually do
So to bring about the Age of Those
Who Live in Death, and considering
Fortissax fights against you,
you could speculate that Fortissax
is still vehemently opposed to death,
and those who live within death, even now.
Check out this video for more on that.
Anyway, so it should come as no surprise
that this friendship between Godwyn
and Fortissax
was seen as significant in Leyndell
when Fortissax was first defeated.
This moment of friendship was so
significant that
it would make allies
of all the ancient dragons,
and give rise to the Ancient Dragon
Cult in the capital city.
It seems the Ancient Dragon Cult
was born out of a desire
to defend the Erdtree.
As stated by the Malformed Dragon Set
"After the great ancient
dragon Gransax attacked,
the tree sentinels had an epiphany.
The only way to truly protect the
Erdtree was to become dragons themselves."
So it was that these regular tree
sentinels
became 'Draconic' Tree Sentinels.
As a fun side note.
The 1.0 description
of the Malformed Dragon Set
instead talks about a dragon worshiper
named Nal,
who I speculate is this individual
defending Maliketh in Farum Azula.
His set once read "Once the dragon
worshiper from the capital,
it's said that he pulverized
his golden armor with his bare hands
in a fit of religious fervor,
covering it in his own blood
as he reshaped it
in the likeness of a dragon."
But anyway, in the final version
of the game, there's more than one
Draconic Tree Sentinel, and they wield
armaments whittled from dragon claws,
so that they could better honor
the ancient who they worship
without resorting
to the primal act of dragon communion.
And conveniently, for them
it was found that dragon
worship
didn't clash with belief in the Erdtree.
The Gravel Stone Seal
says as much, stating,
"After all, this seal, and lightning itself,
are both imbued with gold."
And this goes beyond just color.
The ancient dragons were originally
a part of the Greater Will's plan
back in Farum Azula,
and the golden scales reflect that.
And after the Dragon War, these ancients
became a part of the Greater Will's plan
once more, albeit in a more subservient
role than in their previous age.
One thing that's kind of difficult
to reconcile with the Dragon cult
is the fact that their prayer books,
cookbooks, spells
and even a Draconic Tree
Sentinel can be found in Farum Azula.
Special thanks to V-limit on YouTube
for making me aware of this.
The Ancient Dragon War in Leyndell
would have surely happened
after Farum Azula's age had passed,
so how did all of this
get up there? Either
Farum Azula became sky bound much later
in the timeline than, I thought,
or perhaps Dragon cultists
simply traveled up
to Farum Azula with these relics somehow.
And I think this second
is much more likely, because in an earlier
version of the game Farum Azula,
it was actually called the Storm
Aerie, and was, and
I quote, "a place
that only dragons can reach."
This reminds me
a lot of Dragon Peak and Dark Souls III
which could only be accessed
a sort of draconic meditation.
So perhaps Farum Azula was once
planned to be accessed in a similar way.
For all we know,
it could still be canon that those in tune
with dragons are spirited up here.
For instance, some banished knights
certainly found a way up here,
and they have dragons
cresting their helmets.
And this helmet once described
how they sort
the Storm Aerie,
presumably through revering dragons.
Therefore, I feel like remnants
of characters being spirited up here
due to their association with dragons
is a bit of a hold-over
from a past version of the game
that still exists in the current version.
And while we don't
get spirited up in the current game
by becoming a dragon,
we are certainly spirited up here.
This teleportation occurs
when you sacrifice
Melina or yourself in the Frenzy ending.
Now, mechanism behind
this is kind of unclear,
but there is sort of a prophecy
that helps to explain it.
Melina's Blade of Calling reads
"The one who walks alongside
flame, shall
one day meet the road of Destined Death."
So whether you walk alongside
Melina, the kindling maiden,
or the God of Frenzied Flame,
or you're Alexander tempering yourself
in the flames of Gelmir
and the Giant's Forge, you're going
to make it up here one way or another
and meet the road of Destined Death.
Speaking of which,
this also explains why Bernahl is up here.
According to his Beast Champion Armor,
"his maiden threw herself into the fire,"
just like Melina does for us,
which is what gets us up here
and he, too, also has a fate
that ends with Destined Death,
just like we do.
So there's definitely some sort of fate
associated
with Destined Death
that is spiriting us up here.
I think that's for sure.
And to explain most others up here in Farum
Azula, well again, I personally think
that they will likely spirited up
thanks to their draconic nature,
as explained by the cut content
from that earlier version of Elden Ring.
For all the humans
who desired to commune with dragons,
there was one dragon
who actually communed with humans.
Lansseax.
Lansseax was the sister of Fortissax, and
while you fight her as a dragon in game,
long ago, she took the form of a human
to better commune with the Dragon Knights.
As a priestess of the Ancient Dragon
Cult of Leyndell
the fact that she was able to take
human form is pretty amazing.
This is almost a reflection
of dragon communion.
But instead of changing form
and communing with dragons,
she's changing form to better commune
with humans.
A part of this communion
apparently was love,
and according to Dragon Bolt Blessing,
"only those loved by dragons
can survive the ordeal
of cladding their bodies in lightning."
And of all the knights Vyke the Dragon-
spear
was the one Lansseax loved the most.
Fittingly, Vyke's Dragon Bolt is unique
in that it cloads
him and his spear in red Lightning,
the signature weapon of the ancient
dragons,
reserved up until this point for the beast
men who served them in antiquity.
This also marks Vyke as a dragon cultist.
Therefore, it's kind of crazy
to think that
a dragon cultist almost became Elden Lord.
Something That surely would have
had implications for the age
that would follow, you know,
if Vyke was to take the throne.
This must have made it all
the more painful for many
when Vyke suddenly disappeared,
traveling below Leyndell
to visit the Three Fingers where he was
burned by their frenzy, armor and all.
Knowing that he was a dragon cultist
certainly helps
to explain how he got down here.
The fact that he was surely
this highly regarded member of Leyndell's
dragon cult, you'd think,
would open doors for him within the city.
So Vyke likely
could have made the trip down here easily.
Despite the existence of the Three Fingers
being sacrilegious to the Order
up above, we get little information on
why Vyke made this trip,
but in the end we eventually find him
imprisoned within an evergaol.
And whether this imprisonment
is self-imposed
or not also remains a bit of a mystery.
But anyway, back to Lansseax,
who loved Vyke.
The most interesting thing here with her,
I think, isn't
just the fact that we've learned
that dragons can turn into humans.
It's the fact that dragons can love.
Perhaps this love and powerful emotion
is part of what makes them so loyal.
We see many becoming oath sworn
and then Fortissax, for example,
going so far as to sacrifice himself
entirely for his friend.
And it's this fact that makes the Elden
Lord Placidusax's
abandonment by his god all the more tragic.
That their god would never return,
and eventually a Tarnished
would find their way beyond time,
putting an end
to the Dragon Lord and hewing their
Remembrance into the earth.
In the end,
all that remains is Placidusax's ruin.
"The dying wails of the Dragon Lord
who once dwelled
eternally beyond time."
Thank you for watching.
But before I go, do you want some Elden
ring wall art to adorn your walls.
Well, Displate has
you covered in this video
because they're back helping to support
more Elden Ring lore content.
For a limited time
only, they are giving you
these deals on screen to pick up
some Displates in the next few weeks.
Link in the description.
So, the choice is yours.
You can literally get official Elden
Ring art to adorn your walls.
For example, this shot of Godfrey and Vyke
look absolutely stunning.
But then you can also get some Elden Ring
inspired pieces from my store,
if you like.
For example,
this is Guardian of Moonlight, which
features a dragon defending a moonlight
sword from knightly intruders.
Or you could pick up Early Days, which
gives off some Elden Ring vibes from back
before the game was even released,
if you were around then.
Or if you're a fan of Fromsoftware
games in general,
you could go and pick up The Painted World
with Demon's Souls, Dark
Souls, Bloodborne, Sekiro and Elden Ring
all condensed into one world.
It'll take you hours of scrutiny
to discover
all of the references
that we've hidden in here.
As I've said so many times before,
these prints are made of metal,
they're easy to hang,
and somehow they achieve
this gorgeous color, depth and accuracy
that exceeds
most of the traditional prints
that I've sampled.
Again, links in the description.
And thank you for watching.
It feels good to be back doing Elden
Ring lore.
My goal now is to wrap up everything I can
before the Elden ring DLC drops,
so there should be some good times ahead,
you know,
bringing in the
new year as well.
Before I go,
earlier I shouted out Lowkey's theory
on the Nameless God, as I call them,
and I'd again
like to remind you to go and support Lowkey
and check out the other lore content
for yourself, as well.
And if you have any other suggestions
for other content creators
whose theories you'd like
to see cited in future lore videos,
please let me know
and I'll my best to do that.
Special thanks also to Mispap1
for doing an incredible edit
of this video.
The footage looks amazing,
and it's incredible that he can get this
much quality footage, even for a video
that is an hour and a half long.
So I hope that fact really helps
you guys
watch the content and engage with it.
Thank you again for watching,
and I'll see you in the next video.